and I think it's not even marriage it's
um it's just having a kid exactly that's
the crazy thing I just talked to this
guy um the other day and he wasn't
legally married he just had a kid here
um and what she did was she um went to
like a women's shelter and basically at
the women's shelter they tell the girls
like what to say about the guy based on
his background I know he's some of these
people yeah and so um for him for him he
was Muslim and she basically said that
everything she did the last 10 years she
didn't actually consent to doing because
it was under his control like control
allegedly even though she was fine with
it while they were married yes and then
they don't really get a fair shot in
court yeah and and it took him over a
year to actually get to go to court so
he didn't see his kid for a year with no
evidence yeah